what is the core value
and what core values should you be looking for when you start dating
core values are the fundamental beliefs that you hold as a person
the the characteristic traits that are at the top of your list
the top five things that describe you as a person
or the describe a person that you're interested in dating
why are core values important
well they basically tell you what you're in for
they are what makes up the person that you're with
and if your core values don't align with your partner
score values
I believe that most of the time is why things fail
so what could I should you be looking for
no 1 respect
respect is so huge
so huge if you have a partner that does not respect you
you cannot succeed
you cannot or at least you can't succeed happily
a healthy happy relationship takes respect on both sides
you need to respect them as a person and they need to respect you
so it goes both ways
if you are with someone that you don't feel like you respect
that's a red flag
if you're with someone who doesn't respect you in return
also a red flag
no 2 trustworthy
someone that you can trust
someone that you aren't constantly worried about what they're doing when you're not around
are they texting someone
are they being loyal to you
loyalties another one
someone that you can trust with your future
children if you do decide that something that you wanna do
someone that you can trust to represent you
when you can't be somewhere
trust is so huge
it is fundamental
it is something that you must have for a happy relationship
and not only do you need to be able to trust them
but they need to be able to trust you
so these are things that you can be working on in yourself
as well as looking for an apartment
this is a great place for you to take a look at your own self
and be like wow
where can I get better
where can I work on myself
so that when I do find a partner
I am also all of these things and no
3 because I don't think we have time for more than that right now
honesty which honesty goes hand in hand with being trustworthy but
you have to be able to understand that
the words coming out of your partner's mouth are true
and believe that and know that because if not you will always feel uneasy
you will always feel like you're trying to find something around another corner
believe me I've been there
and not being able to trust your partner is huge in turn
if you have found that you yourself have been in a position in the past
where you felt like you needed to lie
that also a red flag
you yourself need to feel comfortable
enough with your partner to be truthful all the time
you never should feel afraid to tell the truth because of how they might react you
you should never feel afraid to tell the truth
because you're afraid they won't love you for who you are
see where I'm going with that
so all of these core values go both directions
you need to be able to display them to your partner
and your partner needs to be able to display them to you